hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts knowledge portals
accelerating action from genetic data
presented by no Albert director
operations and development knowledge
portals and diabetes research rod
Institute of MIT and Harvard
I am Kaylee Baca bobberts and I will be
your moderator for today's event you're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
bobrucz is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the asset
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions into the
drop down box and click send answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
at the bottom or used to ask the
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner on the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming no Albert I will
now turn the presentation over to her
Thank You Kaylee it's a pleasure to
speak with you today I want to thank the
organizers for inviting me again this
case in my name is no Albert I'm from
the Broad Institute and also
accelerating medicines partnership for
tips diabetes and today I'll be talking
to you about knowledge portals
accelerating action from genetic data
with using type 2 diabetes as a model
but before I begin I felt best to
motivate and to motivate a discussion
about knowledge portal for Teich
diabetes I thought it'd be best to talk
about human genetics as a broadly
valuable tool for biomedical research we
can do cellular and molecular approaches
to studying the stellar biology
biological processes to help inform
prediction prevention treatment but
really our human genetic variation is a
fundamental tool and understand
biology and treating disease and I would
say over the past 15 years there's been
a deluge of information in that space
starting with the human genome project
moving to the hapmap 2,000 genomes and
then into the era of genome-wide
Association studies and then moreover
large-scale sequencing studies and it's
really been quite amazing to be part of
this field myself for the past 15 years
what's been challenging is that we're
really seeing genetics as a science of
data and this is even outdated slide
right now that the brutal Institute
alone we've been lucky to just recently
have sequenced our 100,000th whole
genome and the number of exomes is
growing exponentially as you can see
worldwide and both at the Broad
Institute we've done over 250,000 but
the challenge here is getting this data
to people who can use it and make sense
of it particularly for complex diseases
and the status quo right now is that
these data are all over the world from
various institutions various academic
organizations and various companies and
if you want to interact with this data
you'd have to go to many different
places and in many cases the data aren't
even accessible to you because you may
not be an expert in statistical genetics
or you may not know be part of the
consortiums or collaboration that allow
these data to be available so we
envision a future in the world where
someone could interact with this data
search it query it and actually even
better analyze it so how might we do
that we envision the case that you could
actually bring these data together and
you can imagine that there will be one
place all of the world but you can
imagine certain SiC certain trusted
places where data can be brought
together from various institutions
prospective respecting the provenance
and the location of those data but
harmonizing them together an integrated
way you've seen them representing them
stored storing them such they're
protected but also allowing a user to
interact with them because what's
critical is making these data available
to the world we'll definitely have an
impact on human disease and that's the
mostess a significant contribution that
all these data can actually bring so I
want to offer you one potential solution
of the course of our talk today which is
a knowledge portal with a model and type
diabetes I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about how we're doing that
first and then I'll walk you through
actually how what you
actually use the tool so first my
diabetes well it is a quintessential
complex trait in my opinion it affects
about 45 415 million people worldwide
its pandemic and it also has a very
highly heritable component with a risk
of 30 to 70% and it is the leading cause
of cardiovascular disease and kidney
failure in the world it's an extremely
powerful disease to study from this
perspective so types diabetes has been
really successful I think in human
genetics so as of 2017 there have been
about 150 Louis I associate with type 2
diabetes
so she was candidate gene studies
sequencing studies have done well to
identify low sigh just great but the
challenge is what do all these Louis I
do what are the variants of these low
side to and actually how might we but
you're out there function and even more
over the treatment for types diabetes
because this is an extremely powerful
tool to uncover it but what do you do
with these data once you have them so
the next step is to take these GI
signals and translate them into
biological insights well for that you
need many things come to bury define map
the region you need to know all the
coding changes at the region you need to
know the underlying genes you know the
chromatin states and activities but all
these data need to be integrated such as
you could find the causal gene or
variant at the locus but to do that you
need many approaches and many data sets
and these need to be integrated but they
all have their own data provenance
domain expertise which not and everyone
in the world can be an expert in but
they no need to be mined and integrated
in a way that someone can ask questions
of the data so we present and hopefully
can are getting a little bit closer
typically for diabetes and genetics is
the means to make this data available
not only just a statistical geneticist
who's working in the field who has some
data that they've analyzed for type
diabetes who wants to see it in the
concert of all the other genetic data
available in the world for type 2
diabetes also make it available to the
basic researcher who has a hypothesis
about a gene or a product or a biologist
who's been studying a gene in a lab in a
mouse model for years and they want to
know if you
turbit in a human what is the effect
phenotypically and finally we want to
make better treatments we want to make a
way for people who are in the
pharmaceutical arena to make better
treatments to say of the list of targets
that they might study why might they go
after this one that over another one and
human genetics is one very valuable tool
in that space and finally for clinicians
who observe a sequence variant in that
patient I want to know what the heck it
does so for this for the kind of
soybeans knowledge portal now this has
been around for about three years now
it's open access I mean use a Google
account and today I'm gonna walk with
you how we built it what's underlying
and some of the tools within it which
you can use to search query and analyze
you mention X data or touch diabetes but
in order to do this you really need an
organizational body to support you
someone who really believes in this
mission and so we're very lucky to
partner with the NIH and five
pharmaceutical companies in a
public-private partnership that is
solely at its mission to advance the
understanding of types of diabetes and
it's complications the cornerstone to
love this is a knowledge portal for type
diabetes but also the goal is to
generate more data four types diabetes
and it's complications and enable these
information to be readily available to
the world to support drug discovery and
it's a really unique collaborative model
I think because it's not only just a
bunch of people working together in an
academic setting we're also partnering
with industry in a pre-competitive space
such they're sharing the targets that
they're interested in looking at with us
and they're making them available to
each other which is very cool moreover
there are grants in this funding
opportunity to bring data to bear not
only aggregate data all over the world
but also generate new data relevant to
type diabetes there's also sites funded
to build tools and methods make better
tools and method to integrate and mine
genetics data and all this comes
together with a data coordinating Center
which I'm going to talk about a little
bit because that's really at the anchor
of representing human genetics data to
the world how do you do this how to use
do that vision that I showed you at the
beginning of bringing data from various
sites together analyze it QC it
harmonize it and then make it accessible
yeah portal so for that we'll talk about
the course
objectives that we've achieved with the
type diabetes knowledge portal and we
were hope to be headed so there are
three things going to go through today
one is about the ingest and the analysis
of data how do you build a weight
warehouse or a clearinghouse for these
genetics
then how do you serve it up how would
you want to look at it how would you
want to interact with it but this is the
portal and these I'll walk you through
the various work foals and tools that we
have that you can search the data and
then finally if you've done this
successfully you can scale this to other
diseases particularly related diseases
but moreover all common diseases and
then also you hope that once you've
figured out how to integrate human
genetics data you want to layer other
data types because what what I was
saying earlier in order to actually make
any inference about variants and what
their function is you have to layer in
other data types and allow visual
representation of all those data sites
in concert so first let's talk a little
bit about the ingest and analysis of
data so for that this is really our data
coordinating platform we're very lucky
to be at the Broad Institute where we
are funded to do this and we're very
lucky to represent the community on this
this effort there are four components
and I would say to a data coordinating
platform and all of these need to be
wrapped together in a modular and
flexible software system that can be
ported elsewhere that can be added to
and then can adopt in scale so these
four components I want to talk a little
bit about but the first of them is
engagement and collaboration you can't
do this for every disease unless you
bring the community along with it you
have to have the expertise from that
particular domain that particular
disease to gather requirements what do
they care about in that particular area
you have to collaborate such there's
trust and you have to engage with them
to figure out how you might do this then
you have to have a data ingest and
warehouse platform and for this we did
this manually the first couple years it
was about a handshake with data
providers who are trusting us with
bringing their human genetics data to us
we would work with them on the templates
or transfer how you bring them in and
then analyze it I'll talk a little bit
about that in a minute once you do that
you gotta automate it because you have
to be able to expand to all diseases and
all data types across the world you have
to implement the best practices
the community and finally Federation
because you can't imagine that everyone
day is in one place in the entire
world's gonna have all the genetic state
in the world you have to federate and
allow data sovereignty that says they
can't leave certain places to remain in
their domain
it's a first engagement I'm very lucky
for the past mmm close to 18 years now
I've been involved in a type diabetes
genetics community and I really would
say that that community we were lucky
enough to do our proof of concept
knowledge border with this community
because at the heart
they had trust in data sharing so to
really make success in the G was era you
had to be sharing your results and
people weren't just gonna send all their
la genotype files because you can't do
that because there are ethical
considerations but they were willing to
share the results and a beginning of is
just sharing of these results with these
communities and these consortiums you
see here in this slide to gain trust to
talk about the methods we run the way we
QC our data the way we store it the way
we analyze it and what best practices so
this community was critical to us
because it helped us form the foundation
of how we ingest data what we require of
people what incentives there are for him
them in the community to join this
effort and then bring the data to one
site that is trusted to respect the data
use restrictions of all human genetics
data we're taking in the representation
the analysis and the best tools so for
that over the past couple years we've
been building building a manual
effectively because it's been involving
many people system to bring in all the
data whether it be the human genetics
raw sequence raw genotype data and
summary level statistics if we cannot
get the raw data bring in all the traits
so you have all these deep reach
phenotyping traits not just diabetes but
all the traits that go with it all the
metabolic and cardiovascular traits then
all the ethical documentation that we
store so we knew how we can and cannot
use the data then you have to be able
the system to store it to protect it and
make sure that it's never exposed to the
world in a way that would be in you
against the ethical documentation
underlying then you have to run on the
analysis on the data and then finally if
you're able to do that you can release
and share it in the portal that I'll get
to in a moment
so we've been able to do this manually
for several years but we've also
thankfully been able to turn this into
software such that we can ingest data
from anybody in the world work with them
and in partnership and collaboration
bring their data in and you see it
analyze it for Association two types
diabetes and related traits and all
those methods and tools are there best
practices in the industry and those data
can be represented on a portal that I'll
show you in a minute
if data can't be transferred we're very
lucky because we have a very fast track
system for which data can come in
Association statistics and be
immediately harmonized such that it's
treated exactly as the raw data but it's
all represented in concert for you on
the site but you can imagine if you're
just putting results out there you're
gonna want to be taken seriously right
so you need to balance that open access
with transparency and validity of
results so for our automated pipeline
that runs Association analysis for us we
produced with it your full basically
your materials and methods if you will
for a paper you can drill down to all
the tests we use the statistics we use
we store in the data the full list of
the results in a PDF if you really
choose Manhattan plots the way we're
perfect prepare the phenotypes and the Q
C's we run the principal components all
that is available to you if you were
interested but if you really just want
to look at the results you want to do
that through a portal and I'll get to
that in a minute
so finally what about Federation so
Federation is a great expansion tool in
the sense that all data cannot come to
the Broad Institute we don't want all
the data we want to maintain the domain
in the Providence of many data sets
specifically for data sets that for
example can't leave Europe we want to
make sure that a user can interact with
those data sets wherever they are so
they can log on to the portal they can
run an analysis but they don't know
necessarily where the data are coming
from because it's federated and
Federation we're very lucky to
collaborate with the EBI in the UK who
houses EGA and we now have Federation
with them such that there are data sets
that live in the UK that are treated the
exact same way as we treat them at the
DCC you're here at the road they're
stored cue seed analyzed and represented
in the same way that's when you're
interacting with them on the knowledge
portal you don't know where they came
with came from but the results are
represented to you in a harmonious
fashion but the data are stored
protected at the sites
so that's a really cool advancement for
us we're very happy for that so now that
you've figured out hopefully how to
ingest these data federated and also
automate the software platforms
underneath how do you want to interact
with it so for that you need
visualizations and tools and moreover
workflows ways to actually take you from
a question you might have hopefully to
an answer
so not just result tables and files you
can download but really about an
integrated approach to take you through
a question and really for me this is
about knowledge and guidance rather than
just results so that's what we're
working towards over the past couple
years to build it from just a set of
results to some sort of inference so I
welcome you if you're interested to log
on to the portal this is the front page
you can follow along with me I didn't do
a live demo because who has never worked
so I figured I'd do screenshots but I
take you through several vignettes of
how you might work with the data that I
just spoke about and how you might what
questions you might ask and what you can
do so here's the URL if you want to log
on when you get there this is what it
looks like so the many places you could
jump off from the top bar has you know
your home your variant finder in several
tools but mostly up there is the
policies and the data if you want to
learn about how we built it but that's
not as important is showing you how it
works so first you want to know about
some of the data there in the site well
the data that I spoke about earlier
comes from this human genetics The Times
diabetes genetics community right now we
represent over 30 data sets in about 62
traits and you can see them here it's an
interactive data page so you can click
the different boxes at the top and you
can know what data type so it's G was
exome data exome chip data whole genome
sequencing data and then all the
different phenotypic classes we can
interactively show you what data sets
are available for that trait this
represents integrated representation of
both results derived from denote de novo
genetic analysis of individual level
data but also pre computed statistics so
these are the data how might you work
with it so if you go back out to the
homepage there are sort of three ways
you want to interact with the type
studies knowledge Bowl one is explore a
gene or a variant which I'll show you in
a moment
one is the variant finder which is a
custom analysis tool which I won't go in
today
but I'll touch upon a little bit but the
first to sort of you sort of a new user
and you want to know you know what is
the full genetic Association results
from my phenotype of interest and so for
this you want to go right to that Dhanam
tab hit go where it says type diabetes
and what will bring you to is what's
kind of classic in genomic space is the
representation via Manhattan plot of the
chromosome chromosome and all the
p-values for the types of diabetes and
in the largest data set we have an in
knowledge portal by default so this is
the X text each of the exome chip
analysis which was just recently
published and brought to bear on the
site this same day publication was made
available and so this gives you sort of
like a very high-level look at the
Association statistics across the
chromosome for this particular data set
and you could choose whatever data set
we have in the portal from that
drop-down menu and sort of get a sense
of what all the data sets look like in a
very high level from a genetics
perspective based on p-value that sort
of just like one flavor what did you
want to know something of a bit more
detail you have a variant that you
particularly care about that you've been
studying for years or your statistical
genesis and you have a small data set
for which you've done an analysis and
you have a variant that you have a not
only significant association and you
want to know what else isn't known about
it so by that you can do the top button
right here and click this is our default
variant to give you an idea and you can
go what I would call this page the at a
glance page so this gives you for this
particular variant all the Association
statistics that are nominally
significant right away each box is a
dataset and it's color-coded by its
significance and the top one is the most
significant p-value on the largest data
set this says for all it is that's in
the portal what are the most relevant
for associations type diabetes so this
gives you a sort of like at a glance
gives you God's ratio the direction of
effect the allele so you can see sort of
pertinent information for you but really
what you want to know is what about
other phenotypes do you just have
diabetes what else can I know well you
can also click right below that and see
the Association statistics across all
the traits we have so this will give you
the direction of effects the beta the
allele frequency in every single data
set we have and all the phenotypes we
have
so this is a bit of a Dell user
information it is sort of just a list of
results it's not quite enough for you
you probably want more interactive
however this is extremely useful for a
group of people who are doing
replication or have small data sets for
which they have results or want to do
lookups or something that they think is
very interesting you can see this in one
one use case for some of our colleagues
to use the knowledge portal as an in
silico replication of a variant they had
and they actually publish this along
with their other findings and nature
communications just recently so this
gives you an example of how you can use
the knowledge portal to look up data you
that you know about from a variant of
interest or just learn what we know
about type 2 diabetes genetics in
aggregate but what I think is most
valuable and what's different about the
knowledge portal is that beyond just
results sharing it also integrates
workflows so in the next section and I'm
walk you through an example particularly
from a bit of a group that worked very
closely with us and a project that I'll
use as an example but I'll take you
through the knowledge portal or how you
might walk through what I would call a
workflow and this workflow is around
prioritization of variants for
functional study so for example this was
published in a genetics and on the gene
I'm going to walk you through his CDC
one two three and this was a labor of
love by many of I combined my personal
colleagues actually where they use
genetics I'm mapping and genomic
annotation to find causal variants for
type diabetes at several known G wasps
looking low sigh so what do they need to
do this they need many datasets they
knew the experts of mavens in those
particular fields to help them integrate
those data layer them together and
derive results and it took the many
years lots of data sets and a lot of
work well well you're lucky is we're
lucky because these people now work with
us and they brought their data to bear
in the portal and then you can now use
the knowledge portal where these
datasets are actually visually
integrated for you that you can see some
of these results so let's walk through
this model now so you'll go back to the
main page and you can type in your gene
of interest which is CDC one two three
hit go it'll take you to what we call
our gene page but our gene page for me
is our first sort of workflow page it's
the it's designed to start you at the
and work you down to more distilled and
sort of nitty-gritty granularity
depending on your interest level but
what you start with and when you're here
at the home page is what we call our
traffic light and our traffic light is
an algorithm that helps to take all the
genetic data that is in the knowledge
portal four types diabetes and all the
other phenotypic traits and say right
away is there strong evidence for
signals so if you get a green that means
associated with a particular phenotype
this tells you right away
is there something in this gene that's
worth worth you know noting and so for
this you see the types diabetes and type
2 diabetes adjusted for BMI are
significantly associated with type 2
diabetes I mean with this gene and then
there's other traits for what you see in
yellow that are not only associated and
then in it you'll also see all the other
traits for which we have data in the
knowledge portal and you can click on
all those and see the results so that's
sort of one view and this is algorithm
based tested it's taking all the data
and integrating and giving you the best
evidence but what if you want to see how
we derive that evidence for signal so
for that you want to go to our common
variants tab now historically if you
wanted to do this you'd have to go to
various Jewish sites the diagram magic
which are these large scale consortium
for types IVs and related traits pull
down the data yourself integrated have a
lot of domain knowledge in that space
and pull it all together what you have
here it's all distilled for you it pulls
it all together and it rolls up for you
the best p-value and the best data set
for that common variant for type
diabetes so that's right there for you
and you can peruse down through and see
all of the variants but what do you want
if you want to know about high impact a
coding variation at this particular
locus you know the next tab that if this
gene which doesn't have any coding
variations in it you would have you
would see all the high-impact variant
results for type diabetes but what we do
do is if there are low frequency
variants from a sequencing that are here
in CBC one two three you will also get
the aggregate variant test results right
there pre computed for you but that's
just one view you want to go deeper you
might want to say hmm I want to see
what's around the site so this is a you
know a gold standard in the field locus
zoom gives you your reagent view this
using many papers that represent you
know any fun mapping for type study I
mean common diseases gol signals that is
so you can go here you can select your
phenotype you can select your data set
and then you can see in Manhattan I mean
I look at soon plot for all the variants
at this site since again is a different
view of all the association's statistics
for CDC one two three in a particular
window and if you want to rare
integrated datasets the relevant tissue
expression data you can layer on
underneath it so you can get sort of a
region view of this locus all the
Association statistics and all the genes
underlying it but this doesn't give you
all you need if you want to prioritize
variants for functional study you want
to know what's the best variant I might
go on if I want to go perturb it
understand its function and actually
know what is actually going on at this
particular locus so not you want to go
to our credible sets tab this brings you
to the a for a given region the best
variance that you would want to
functionally follow-up and study
moreover it actually then layers the
tissue and the regulatory information on
top of it such you can see which is the
best variant for studying what you'll
see here is it the best variant from the
Association analysis is not the one with
the best functional datasets you'll see
the one that's got the yellow and orange
tracks is one overlaps with adipose
tissue have G juices tissues and islets
so this from the posterior probability
is the most likely variant that you want
to follow up for function and this
recapitulates the same snip that we
found the golden and all paper so this
shows a way of layering the G us that
the genetic data affine mapping data and
the annotations the tissue and
expression data in one visualization
assistant you can mine it and ask a
question about it in that manner
however that's all pre computed what if
you want to go deeper what if you want
to do analyses that are hard to pre
compute because they're computationally
heavy what if you want to know how many
independents associations are there a
locus do conditional analysis that
requires interact
if analysis what if you want to run an
aggregate gene level Association for a
custom set of variants that you are
choosing on a set of samples that you
want to choose so this is where we get
into sort of I would call our sort of
hypothesis testing or generation space
so everything I told you about earlier
was about seeing results represented
from pre compute its association
statistics whether we did it on the raw
sequencing data and genotype data or
from summary level statistics that we
had a graffitied and integrated but
these two tools I'm gonna talk to you
about are interactive in the sense that
when you're asking that particular
question on this site it is calling data
on the fly and interactively running
that in on the raw sequence and genotype
level under the hood protect it and then
bouncing to you back the results this is
a very cool tool in my opinion because
this allows you to ask questions of the
data on the fly based on hypothesis so
for that you can go to our main page and
I'm going to use tcf7l2 which is a gold
standard and type diabetes genetics as
an example they'll bring you to the the
gene page as I showed you earlier and
showed you the top associations for both
the phenotypes that are significant and
not only associated but to do this you
want to go down here to the locus zoom
tab again
so first what if you want to do
conditional analysis what do you want to
know you want to know is what's the best
signal at this particular locus and what
are their snips might be contributing to
the site the signal excuse me so for
here you want to pick one of the data
sets for which we have individual level
data and here's an example so this isn't
our dynamic module you'll see static
which is based on summer level
statistics and if you select that it
will bring up for you this med some
study which is an example of 9,000
people we have with individual level
data and then you can select the top
snip and you can run the conditional
analysis on that particular variant and
this will use interactive analysis so
we'll use a tool called Hale which has
been developed at the Broad Institute
which uses is run in the cloud and it
runs dynamic Association statistics for
you and represents the results back to
you on the fly
so if you do that that's what you'll get
produced and you'll see by conditioning
upon that snip what is the results that
that what are the other snips assert or
are there other singles at the locus
that are contributing to the signal and
again you'll get the layering of the
tissues and whatnot so that's one
interactive module the next one which I
find is really exciting to me actually
which is our gait tool so this is to run
allow you to customize the variants you
want to analyze and the phenotypic
criteria you want to use so for that
I'll give you another great example
using slc30a8 again you'll go to the
gene page for that you'll type it in and
you'll see that is associated type
diabetes but you want to know
basically what snips that are you know
protein truncating for example are
associated with type diabetes so for
that you want to go down to the
high-impact variants tab and you want to
go to run a custom burden test and for
this you'll come up with what our gait
tool and there's a guide there if you
want to look through it and I'll tell
you give you some inference about how
you might make your selections but first
you want to pick your phenotype of
interest and we'll start with diabetes
you can also stratify by ancestry you
can you can do your result stratified by
ancestry and there are five within the
knowledge portal then you want to pick
your variants and this you can pitch by
the variant filters here I'm picking
protein truckin truncating and missense
with a minor allele frequency of less
than 1% and for that then you wanted
then though those variants and you can
pick and choose which ones you want if
you only want a few of these you can
click click and highlight which ones you
want next step is you want to select the
subset examples based on fits phenotypic
criteria so for that you'll see that we
have 18,000 samples from whole exome
sequencing available for you to query so
these are interactive analyses such you
can run on the raw sequence data
protected under the hood safely at the
data coordinating Center so for this you
can select for example if you wanted to
look at the different crises on
different phenotypes for which you can
select on and filter based on a criteria
that you have so what if you want to run
by BMI for example you can type in a
criteria that you would have it'll
automatically show you what samples you
would be drawn from at that particular
time then you'll be launching the
analysis and for this and then finally
your step would you control for
covariance we have your standard PCs you
would control for and then you would
launch the analysis launching an
analysis runs Anna so she
analysis of burden test on the fly for
you on the 19,000 exomes that are hidden
sitting behind the firewall and
represents you the results on the fly I
found this to be one of the coolest
modules sort of that differentiates from
just results sharing but allows you if
you are sort of a maven or a very
interested in Association statistics you
can actually do some hypothesis testing
or actually moreover some inference on
the site with interactive raw sequence
data just own but only representing
results so these are sort of some of the
vignettes I want to take you through and
you may be wondering who's using this
site you know it's it's not Google it's
not even close but we're very lucky that
we have about seven thousand users which
i think is pretty cool we're very
excited with that what's really cool is
that we have about a hundred enter
active users a day across the world but
66% of them are coming back which I find
really to be the most gratifying in the
sense it is useful to them in their
research which is perhaps the most
important thing and the average
connection time is about eight minutes
and that means people are hopefully not
just you know landing on the pay's and
leaving they're trying to do some things
and we'd like to extend that because
we'd really want them to be using the
site getting us feedback and hopefully
making it better so in the final few
minutes I want to take you through the
last component of the knowledge portal
which is scaling to other diseases and
other data types and for this we'll talk
about two things places where we've
scaled there's once you've done this
four types of diabetes really what our
users have been asking for is famous
times related to size diabetes because
four types of diabetes
most people don't die of type diabetes
that die of all the complications so
micro micro and macro vascular
complications of type 2 diabetes are
really what they care about knowing if
they can protect and prevent so for that
they want us to bring in data sets from
cardiometabolic spaces and other related
phenotypes but to do that you also need
to engage at the larger communities so
we thought we'd start small there and
we're very blessed so once you built
this architecture you build this
architecture such that it's nimble
enough to respond to other diseases and
the importance then is you need to
engage at that community understand
their different needs
things that are very important to them
in their space how they feel about data
sharing what they want to make shared
and what incentives are important to
their community so for that we were
lucky to partner with Jonathan Rhodes
and the International struction X
consortium because they were very
interested in this model and we're able
to build them a portal for cerebral
vascular disease which just launched
almost a year ago now and this is built
in the exact same software framework
stay and ingest mechanism same analysis
mechanism but with this best practices
from the stroke genetics community and
viewed on the analysis such as
represented in the way that community
needs their data represented but the
principles are the same it's all
associations cestus dicks same test same
sort of structure and then also the same
portal framework to represent the data
but what we've been very lucky with
these people to work with these these
colleagues is they've been thinking
about other ways that they want to
advance the knowledge portal tool so if
you just to give you a brief summary of
what's here there are about 80,000
samples and these are all these all
allow you to interact with the exact
same ways that I showed you earlier the
same structure on the same function but
they've had a couple other vignettes to
it so their data sets you can see them
interactively the same way as you would
for the type 2 diabetes knowledge portal
but they have about 19 data sets and 45
traits but what they've done is they
found it was really important for them
in their community to make all these
data tist extendable because they wanted
it to be they wanted to go one step
further and say you know what if it's
published you can have access to it you
can put a copy on your hard drive so
we've added that feature tip for their
particular community that's only useful
if you can do the analyses downstream
with the soda summary statistics but you
can use the portal if you're not an
expert to interact with all these data
that are sitting right here
additionally we also had a great
collaboration with this this group
because they were interested not only in
allowing people to see results but also
allowing people to do their own sort of
analysis on individual level data not
necessarily protective so for example
while we allow custom analysis
you only see results some people some
communities really are just trying to
allow their other analysts within the
community to have access to the data
that they normally wouldn't so create
for lack of a better term and worse
workflow or a sandbox for which they
could protect in a protected space
interact with individual level data and
ask their own questions of it so add
their own tools little modules so we're
very lucky to partner with the aah a
precision medicine platform to bring to
bear some of those tools let me talk
about that real quickly except for here
if you go on the site to this particular
data set you can go to the data set
you'll find out all the relative of the
publication's for this data set but you
also could click on that the aah a logo
there and it will bring you to their PMP
which is a totally different URL it's
just it brings you out of the knowledge
portal framework to the aah a PMP site
where you can log in again account but
what they offer in that particular space
is they offer access to individual level
data and you can create these workspaces
where you can run notebooks based on
cheaper to notebooks of analyses store
your results and make ask questions of
the data and a protective environment so
what's cool is the knowledge portal
framework offers you access to the
results this office use particular drill
down to data sets that are available in
this particular space this is very
useful for you know analysts who have a
particular tool they run on one of the
data that they couldn't do normally so
they can ask for access to this
particular data set and use this as a
model for them and you can see this is
what it looks like so that's kind of a
neat code development we were able to do
working with great collaborators so
we're also lucky we're also lucky to
partner with sake our path reason and
Patrick Eleanor who are colleagues to
actually have the office down the hall
for me to build a knowledge portal for
cardiovascular disease and this was just
launched in November and this site again
the exact same underlying software
architecture same data types but totally
different phenotypes very lucky to be
associated you know interesting for type
diabetes because all these phenotypes
are remarkably interest us from diabetes
but we're really lucky because they
really wanted to get their data out to
the world timed with publication they
wanted to allow people to have the exact
same question
that we allow with the types of diabetes
knowledge portal to me to be made
available for cardiovascular disease so
for this site you will see 23,000
early-onset m eyes samples available
from exome sequencing they're available
for interactive analysis 154 samples for
atrial fib 300,000 samples for lipids
it's really remarkable amount of
datasets that this group is brought to
bear and what's awesome about this group
is they have their own team of analysts
statistical geneticists and methods
developers who are thinking about new
ways to look and visualize the data and
we're working with them to integrate
their tools as well so again the same
framework here again I was mentioning
many datasets same same sort of type of
datasets but again four different
phenotypes and you can interact with
those in the exact same way you can
interact with them four types IPS and so
and then one other thing just to give
you example to this dataset we know
what's made available earlier this this
year for 3,000 samples with lipids these
are on the site for you to query so one
of the things we've been working with
the cardiovascular group is every
publication that they now have we time
it such that the results go live on the
knowledge portal the same day as
publication so you can see the results
you see the paper and then that same day
you can go to the knowledge portal and
you can see all the results and ask
questions about them this has been we
found this to be a remarkably cool and
valuable tool as you publish and as you
allow people to interact with your data
but what about other additional
expansion so for that we're also very
lucky because we've been collaborating
with many other groups both locally here
and at the broad and muscle
internationally to develop beta sites
because these people have you know
different communities where they may not
want to make their data readily
available to the world just yet but they
have tools that they want to get out
they have data they want to get out and
they're really trying to socialize this
idea so there's three portals for which
we've developed beta sites we're hoping
to release over time once from film
Ettore bowel disease ones for epilepsy
and ones for sleep disorders but all
these have slightly different calissa's
to them
one is they interact and they interact
in the integration of epigenomics data
and other data
is heating one of them they also have
different ways of representing results
the epilepsy has gene level test they
want to represent right away so we've
been working them to develop interfaces
for that sleep genetics our colleagues
there just want a way of getting their
data out upon publication and that's
really important to them because they
found that that's been very limiting to
them as even in their collaborative
space we're also expanding to new
disease communities including Elsa MERS
disease Parkinson's disease ALS and
lipid biology so what's exciting about
this is this is teaching us how to
expand the software platform but also
integrate and collaborate with other
people who have different ways to
represent and visualize the data so then
finally we talked about scaling to other
diseases one point before I end about
other data types so we've talked a lot
about human genetics and I think we've
done a good job of bringing not those
results to bear in a way that you can
interact with them in ways you probably
couldn't three years ago even but what
about layering of other data types
particularly for this vignette I was
mentioning earlier where you want to
prioritize variants for functional study
or you want to know about other data
sets that are relevant to types diabetes
how do you bring those together because
there are many approaches as I mentioned
earlier there are mouse models
regulatory variants expression data it
goes on what you want to be able to do
is make sure that all the data being
generated from those those various
approaches has the relative DOE data
provenance respected because we're not
going to be an experts in every data set
but also bring the schema or the
relevant information and knowledge
represented in a visualization that
gives you the right information that you
might want based on your query so this
is going to be a long active process but
for us what we're starting with is using
the model of Federation the reason
Federation is critical is because we
can't reinvent the wheel for for example
what encode has done for years or what
gtex has done for years we want to
leverage their work and integrate it
such that it represents the domain of
that particular field but integrates it
in the way that answers the questions
that people might want to ask for the
particular disease or phenotype or
variant that they're asking about it so
the place where we've made some inroads
there is through
earlier Federation and I call it
integration by Federation because it's
the integration with epigenomics data
it's our colleagues at the University of
San Diego are working with us because
they have all the raw epigenomics
information data stored queue seed
analyzed in the way that's best from
that particular field and now on the
knowledge portal in the coming months
when you query those those tissue layers
that I was showing you it won't just
come from our repository here at the
data coordinating so that they will come
from the epigenomics Federation that is
at UCSD bounce to you and represented
for it to you session we can bring in
individual level data sets we never
normally could you have the domain
expertise from that world and it's all
integrated for you on one site and so
we're hoping to be able to expand that
two different approaches and data sets
such that we make it such that people
don't feel like they have to bring all
their data in one place they can
actually feder a twith us and it creates
a way of enabling far more datasets to
come to there so where are we headed as
I mentioned earlier we want to expand
this platform to ingest more new data
types and new analysis capabilities
we're really hoping to reach out to
other disease communities and figure out
what types of questions they want to ask
we want to bring sites together also in
the same space you can imagine four
types of diabetes what's relevant to
type diabetes is also relevant for heart
attack so you can imagine these sites
coming together at some point into a
Kearney metabolic site and our
collaborators are really keen to do that
because they want to leverage all the
data inside of both because many of the
datasets and types diabetes those
samples have trade data on heart attack
or lipids same with data sets that might
be relevant to cardiovascular disease
they're going to have type 2 diabetes
status so if you can make the community
comfortable sharing in their own
community you can imagine a world where
they're sharing their cross and for that
you just have to have that very strong
software platform underneath that is
nimble enough to to add in the different
communities but represent the data in an
integrated fashion so that's one way
we're developing we're also developing
into new disease communities who have
different ways of card station of
variants who have ways of
representing the data who have different
datasets to bring to bear who have
strong connections with bio banks for
example those other places were really
hoping to expand moreover on Make a
Porno more useful we're going to create
new and enhanced workflows and
visualizations that incorporate
different data types and layering sort
of like the uber UCSC browser if you
will if we could ever get that that good
at what we do
and finally what a scale incorporates
news DS communities such that it's open
access for every disease that's
interested in building this so this is
hopefully start at the beginning for us
and we I'm looking forward to answering
questions but I want to thank the people
that I get to do this every day with
this is the knowledge to what knowledge
portal development team again we're
across oceans and borders it is really
cool because it's a soft a joint
software development effort it's not
just here at the road it's at the
University of Michigan and EBI and UCSD
I greet people that get to work with
these are the people I get to see every
day who are computational biologists
engineers and various leaders of the the
effort that I get to work with and also
like the person thing participants in
the MTG partnership for their guidance
and funding and helping us think about
these complex problems and making them
better and with that I'll end then take
any questions thank you Thank You Noel
for that we will now start the life to a
next course if you have a question you'd
like to ask let's cook on the asset
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation like your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
later as many of your questions as we
have time let's get started our first
question asks what makes the type 2
diabetes knowledge portal different than
other human genetics at a result of
postures hmm well I think there's
several reasons I think one is that it
allows it is specific words disease so
it's not just agnostic whereas you can
imagine Nomad is agnostic to disease and
you know that II a thousand genomes and
the other representations though it's
not it's specific core disease so it's
tailored
the other thing that I think is useful
is that it brings individual level data
that's been analyzed in a harmonious
fashion by one organization with the
best practices and tools garnered from
that disease community and it also
brings Tibet get to bear all the
Association statistics that normally
you'd have to go to the various
different sites so instead of having to
go to a gos repository here for this
data set to here for this data set and
here for this data set we actually do an
active process of constantly aggregating
updating refreshing that data and
bringing it together so that you have it
in one place I think the most useful
tool though is its distillation and sort
of the knowledge so it represents for
you sort of the best results you're
supposed to look at that would be
relevant to you know prioritization of
variants or most causal or most
associated but then it also sort of so
it guides you towards the high level but
it also allows sort of a custom view
where if you want to run your own
analyses and you don't want to go to the
individual level data meaning like
having to request access and go to some
you know terminal and run our and
represent the data you can actually in a
very nice UI ask a question that runs
interactively on the underlining key
wasps or excellent sequence data and
represents the results to you so you
don't actually see in the individual
level data so it protects all the data
but it gives you the results on the fly
so again think that makes it different
it almost makes different in the sense
that it's open access anyone can have
access to do it and we're actively
seeking collaboration so it's not just
about you know send your data to us we
want to collaborate with you so we want
to write papers off the things we find
together we want to work together we
want this to be incentive for you
hopefully thank you we have time for one
more question and this ask but if I
wanted to contribute data or tool how
might I do that and what are the
incentives it's good question I think
the incentives were still you know I
think it's a bit of for the greater good
but I'll talk a little bit more about
that how might you do that first of all
if you just want to do it off the site
there's a tab in the front that says
collaborate with us and this walks you
through what it would mean to
collaborate or you can just contact me
but the collaborate to me really
you're interested in bringing your
results you might have some samples for
which you don't have an analysis run you
want someone to analyze the data we can
do that you will do that for you with
you in partnership with you and you get
the results immediately to you back to
you
Grover you get to see your results in
concert with all the other types i beez
to the next result so for that it's
summary statistics are easy we make it
super easy hopefully no work for you we
have a very simple way for which you can
actually bring your with summary level
statistics to us we will load them for
you we can actually make them publicly
available upon publication I think
that's an incentive for many people
because many many publications are
requiring that you have that right now
it's a nice alternative to DB gap in the
sense that you really don't want to make
you all your investigators go get your
data from the various sites and request
access and it takes a long period of
time they just want the results they'll
immediately have these in the knowledge
portal so hopefully it's an incentive
for people to share data because it
makes it easier for them it doesn't
require heavy ethical restrictions
because we again we don't share any
individual level data we only share
results so we hope that's an incentive
because you know you're you're part of
sharing your data on the fly but you
also get access to all these data right
away in concert with your own so
hopefully that would make it useful I
would like to once again thing know
Albert for her presentation I would also
like to thank lab bricks for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing your August 2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again goodbye